do you remember five months ago when dr
fauci testified unequivocally before the
senate that the nih
had not funded gain of function research
related to the wuhan institute of
virology
senator paul with all due respect you
are entitled entirely
and completely incorrect
that the nih has not ever and does not
now
fund
gain of function research
in the woohon institute do they find our
doctor barrick
we do not fund do you find dr barracks
gain of function research
dr barrett does not doing gain to
function research and if it is it's
according to the guidelines and it is
being conducted in north carolina no i
don't think it's turning up now fauci's
statement was always pretty suspect and
rand paul nails him here because fouchy
simultaneously denies that the research
took place at all ever and also says
that it's perfectly fine we're not doing
gain of function research but you know
even if we are it's totally cool it's
great well we now know that fouchy's
statement was
completely
one hundred percent false
just last wednesday the nih principal
deputy director lawrence toback informed
a republican congressman that the nih
actually did fund gain of function
research
and it wasn't just in north carolina as
faux insisted but in china
in wuhan
at the wuhan institute of virology on
bat coronaviruses i'm michael knowles as
the michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment from friday is from paul helton
who says the political instability is
about enough to make a sane person want
to go off the grid well of course that's
true not just now that's true all of the
time i think there is this inclination
especially among conservatives to just
kind of go out into the woods
go get a gigantic farm somewhere and
just
get out of this insane political life
but we are called
to politics we are we are the political
animal we live in society
when conservatives completely back off
the politics that's when we lose the
whole culture and the country suffers so
we actually have to go back in there and
not just in this kind of squishy live
and let live way
we have to go in with our own political
vision and wield that political power
and make sure that our opponents cut it
out and get in line
but i understand the impulse okay and
there are things that we can do to be
really wise to hedge our investments for
instance to protect ourselves against
kind of some of the political craziness
one way would be to check out acre gold
acre has figured out an ingenious way to
let you invest in physical gold without
coming out of pocket all at once without
trying to find a lot of money in your
couch cushions without because listen i
know
investing in physical precious metals
can be an expensive undertaking what if
i told you you could do it for as little
as 30 bucks a month you're a liar
michael don't call me a liar i'm not a
liar aker just figured it out you
subscribe when the price of your gold
stash reaches the price of their gold
bars they will discreetly ship acre gold
to your house they've also got a 100 a
month subscription to a 5 gram gold bar
they keep you updated on your stash
every month and they ship once you reach
the threshold it's phenomenal i have
really enjoyed investing in physical
precious metals and in acre gold
especially right now with janet yellen
telling us that inflation is going to
keep going on for well over a year
maybe it's worth checking out
getacregold.com start investing in
physical gold today make sure you go to
that url acres giving away a gold bar to
qualify for the giveaway tweet or post
why you should be the recipient and
mention at get underscore acre that is
getacregold.com
knowles thank you akergold for
supporting the show do you remember this
is going to be a nice trip down memory
lane this episode do you remember when
dr fauci
unequivocally 100 no we have nothing to
do with the gain of function research oh
actually we do and we funded it and we
funded it in wuhan do you remember when
joe biden said that he opposed vaccine
mandates
well now he's he's completely
changed his point of view so for quite a
long time he said i oppose it i oppose
it i oppose it now he of course is
attempting to issue vaccine mandates and
here's how he explains this change in
his perspective
should police officers emergency
responders be mandated to get vaccines
and if not should they be
stay at home or let go yes and yes
[Applause]
by the way
by the way i waited until uh
july
to talk about mandated because i tried
everything else possible
the mandates are working all the stuff
about people leaving and people goodness
you have you have everyone for united
airlines to spirit all these airlines
we're not going to get
all 96 97 percent of the people have
gotten the vaccine all the talk about
all these folks who are going to leave
the military if they're mandated not
true you got about a 90 some percent
vaccination rate so
uh joe biden is fudging the numbers a
little bit here because it's true that a
lot of organizations are getting up to
pretty high levels of vaccination but a
lot of organizations are also laying a
ton of people off united airlines what
was it last week or two weeks ago
fired something like 600 employees
because they didn't want to take the
fouchy aochie so sure other
organizations are doing this too people
are quitting people are letting their
contracts expire people are being fired
outright so sure that's when you fire
all the unvaccinated people then your
numbers for vaccination are going to go
up but but in a lot of cases companies
including airlines are pushing back
against the mandates delta airlines one
of the biggest
kind of a liberal airlines one of the
biggest airlines in the united states
though just came out last week and
backtracked and said no we're not going
to force our guys to get the vaccine
they don't want to get it it's wrong
we're going to lose a lot of our of our
fleet and so we're just not going to do
it we're going to back off that mandate
southwest the same thing there was a
sick out a couple of weeks ago on
southwest airlines the pilots and the
other workers didn't want to get the
vaccine and so southwest is backing off
the mandate now they've come out and
said we oppose the vaccine mandate
police departments are dealing with this
chicago pd they're expecting 40 to 50
percent to walk off the force tsa tsa
has reportedly had a number of sick outs
this is al also one of the reasons why
the airlines were all screwed up a
couple of weeks ago
all right all so joe biden is making
these really strong claims the mandates
work the mandates work well yeah it
works if you fire all of the people who
aren't going to go along with it but
you're going to have serious
economic and political repercussions
from that what does this boil down to
boils down to people's right
to make in this case their own medical
decisions when they don't face a grave
risk from the virus necessary for most
people when the vaccine is brand new it
uses in some cases brand new vaccine
technology there have been proven side
effects some of which have been deadly
that's why they paused one of the
vaccines what does joe biden say he
laughs he scoffs at your silly idea of
freedom
the two things that concern me one are
those who just try to make this a
political issue freedom
i have the freedom to kill you
with my copy
no i mean come on freedom free come on
freedom ugh disgust you [ __ ] you peepee
peasants
freedom
what you have the freedom to kill people
with your if you are unvaccinated this
is what joe biden's saying if you're
unvaccinated you are putting the
vaccinated people at risk because if you
have the vaccine
you can't spread the virus and you can
you can't contract the virus presumably
but you certainly as joe biden is
implying here can't spread it to others
except that isn't true even if you're
vaccinated you can still spread it to
others this is what the cdc said at the
end of july this is why
the vaccinated are still being required
to wear masks according to cdc guidance
this is why
people are being told to socially
distance and still take all of these
precautions
this is why people are being told maybe
don't go to christmas this year maybe
you don't go to thanksgiving this year
this is this is why all of these things
are happening so it's it's
both in the particular the idea that
once you're vaccinated everything's
totally fine that's being contradicted
by the cdc the idea that you're go the
vaccinated are at great risk because of
the unvaccinated is being contradicted
by the cdc because we're still being
told if you're vaccinated you have a
very low risk of hospitalization or
death and in the broad
principle here the idea that
americans are are just too wedded to
their freedom and you've got to give up
your freedom and take the fouchyache
whether it's the the president telling
you to do so whether it's the
occupational safety and health
administration telling you to do so
whether it's all these kind of
bureaucrats and technocrats
whose power i can't exactly locate in
the american political tradition it's a
contempt
for your freedom it's a contempt for
your way of life it's a contempt
for you and it's never going to end by
the way because i was just citing the
cdc and how the goal posts keep moving
well there they have moved the goal
posts very very far the director of the
cdc has just come out and said they're
going to change the definition
of fully vaccinated right now we don't
have booster eligibility for all people
um currently so we are going to we have
not yet changed the definition of fully
vaccinated um we will continue to look
at this we may need to update our
definition of fully vaccinated in the
future but right now what i would say is
if you're eligible for a booster go
ahead and get your booster and we will
continue to follow
so right now the cdc the fda the the
administrative health bodies refuse to
say that the boosters are safe for
everybody
so unfortunately we can't mandate that
they all take a third shot or a fourth
shot or a fifth shot or it's going to go
on forever but when we can
says the cdc director we're very likely
going to change the definition of fully
vaccinated do you see how this goes
do you get it yet
since those 15 days to slow the spread
since easter at least of 2020
we have pointed out that uh
the
the argument that if you just comply
with one
more requirement then they're going to
let us all be free again that that was
bogus actually the opposite was true a
lot of people a lot of well-meaning
naive gullible people thought oh if i
just wear the mask then we can get back
to society
if i just take the shot then we can get
back if i just take the second shot if i
just take now the third shot if i just
take if they can change the definition
of fully vaccinated and if they can take
all of your political rights and
and have them all depend upon whether or
not you're fully vaccinated then it's
never going away
and i think people are beginning to wake
up and get that
and by the way what the cdc director is
saying is if you refuse and if you can
somehow avoid the dubious
mandates
the mandates of dubious legality that
the white house is putting out well okay
we've got a plan for you we're going to
put you into counseling
there is a plan
should these people not want to be
vaccinated towards education and
counseling to get people the information
they need so that they are feeling
comfortable in getting vaccinated that's
fine oh you don't want to get that it's
okay we're just going to put you in a
re-education camp we're just going to
put you for your own good
into some counseling
because if you object to taking an
experimental drug for a virus that for
most people doesn't pose a grave threat
that was developed and in some cases
produced using the stem cells from
aborted babies if you object to that in
any way it's because you're crazy you're
a lunatic there's no and or because
there are side effects that have been
pretty serious and included death in
some people and their academic studies
to back this up if you you're just crazy
and you need to be corrected and you
need to be re-educated and that's the
respect that your ruling class has for
you not very much respect
at all it makes
you
want to look for any sort of
benefit in this society and just any way
to get ahead as everyone's coming after
you well one way to get ahead i would
strongly recommend you check out get
upside i'm not sure that a sponsor for
this show has ever come in at a more
opportune time than get upside what does
get upside do
saves you money on gas certainly needed
right now our listeners are making up to
25 cents for every gallon of gas every
time they fill up how's it work just
download the free get upside app in the
app store or google play right now use
promo code knowles canon wles get a
bonus 25 cents per gallon on your first
fill up that's up to 50 cents cash
back do not pay full price at the pump
anymore it's crazy get cash back using
get upside down load the app for free
use promo code knowles can owles to get
up to 50 cents per gallon cashback
on your first tank some people who drive
a lot are making as much as two or three
hundred dollars a month in cash back and
there's no catch the cash back gets
added right to your account you can cash
out any time to your bank account paypal
an e-gift card for amazon and other
brands just download the free get upside
app use promo code knowles canon wles
get up to 50 cents per gallon cashback
on your first tank that is code knowles
k-w-l-e-s
so the ruling class is saying give up
your freedom give up your rights give up
your way of life
freedom
come on man says joe biden that's what
they're telling you
and
what are they offering you in return
usually when
demagogues try to take away your freedom
they do so in this clever way they offer
you a bunch of goodies in return they'll
offer you money they'll offer you bread
they'll offer you circuses they'll offer
you employment
they'll they'll
entice you with goodies to get you to
give up these greater political goods
but this ruling class is so stupid and
incompetent they can't even offer you
that what what is the ruling class
giving you
in in exchange for your freedom high
unemployment they're offering you
a
terrible work conditions so you know
a labor shortage that somehow still
can't be filled uh they're offering you
crazy mandates from your employer
they're taking away christmas they're
taking away your holidays they're taking
away your travel they're what are they
giving you they're not giving you
anything
at all
and and what is the answer that they
have you say hold on joe biden i gave
you my freedom i gave you my way of life
i gave you this
how come even the cost of consumer goods
is going up how come i'm paying more for
gas i'm paying more for my food i can't
go live my normal life
they have no answer for it
so there's there there but i i don't i
must tell you i don't have a near-term
answer
there's two things i could do i could go
on the petroleum reserve
and take out and probably reduce
reduce the price of
gas maybe
18 cents or so a gallon it's still gonna
be above three bucks
but it's going to be hard it's going to
be hard there's a possibility to be able
to bring it down depends on
a little bit on saudi arabia and a few
other things that are
in the office
but i don't have an answer man look i
could come on what am i gonna
i gotta go if i do the one thing it
won't work that well and then i don't
know man come on man i don't know i
don't know right they don't know they
don't
know
anything
when
when the
president or one of his advisors or one
of the experts tells you this is what's
going to happen
you should doubt it i at least have a
little bit of respect for biden here in
that he's admitting they have no idea
what they're doing i don't know the gas
thing man come on man i don't know
because usually what happens with these
people is they tell you emphatically
this will happen
this did happen we did i
senator paul we did not we how dare you
senator paul suggest that the nih funded
gain of function research in that is
completely 100 incorrect
except except we did except we did and
the nih is actually admitting that now
this happens again and again and again
janet yellen treasury secretary said
back in july that the rising prices
would only last for several months and
then it would be fine no big deal janet
yellen was just asked why why do the
prices keep going up how long is this
going to go on for she says oh buckle up
it's going to go on for a long time
this rising inflation is hitting
americans while it's hard impacting
everything from gas prices to groceries
when do you expect the inflation to get
back to the you know two percent range
which is considered normal 2022 2023
when
well i expect that to happen next year
monthly rates of inflation have already
fallen substantially from the very high
rates that we saw in the spring and
early summer
on a 12-month basis the inflation rate
will remain high uh into next year
because of what's already happened
but i expect improvement uh by the end
of by the middle to end of next year
second second half of next year
hold on we went from
in july 2021 don't worry the inflation's
only going to go on a few more months
to yeah i expect some improvement by the
end of 2022
would that happen pretty quick
kind of like how 15 days to slow the
spread became
sure we're gonna be done by early summer
or late i guess late spring
of 2020 we're going to be done with this
becomes actually spring of 2022. there's
no reason to believe janet yellen's
right about it ending at the end of next
year
they're wrong about everything
janet yellen was wrong just a few months
ago so why do we believe that she's
right now
the public health bureaucrats were wrong
have been consistently wrong since early
2020. why do we believe that they're
right now joe biden got to give the guy
credit he's completely incompetent not a
whole lot going on between the ears he's
disingenuous he's a liar he's all of
those terrible things but at least he's
admitting here yeah we have no
clue
what we are doing
right now
members of our congress
are being silenced
for saying that men are not women okay
that's the level of lie and lies and
delusion and fantasy that we are living
in
representative jim banks
tweeted out this bizarre observation
that the first female four-star general
or first female four-star admiral
according to the mainstream media and
the public health establishment
is this this guy
dr richard levine who now goes by rachel
who
is the
assistant secretary for health
quite an indictment of the country well
he was suspended from twitter for saying
that because our ruling class doesn't
know anything about covid doesn't know
anything about inflation doesn't know
anything about
how to run the country or the economy
doesn't even know that men are not women
these these are the experts these are
the geniuses
so jim banks
republican congressman
kicked off twitter for this people are
saying the ones who are defending his
suspension from twitter are saying that
what he said was rude that it's rude to
tell this
or not even to tell it's not like he was
directing this at richard levine to tell
this
society that
mr levine is not actually a woman even
though he pretends to be a woman that
this is rude this is cruel a
compassionate society would would just
indulge this delusion and pretend that
levine is is a woman
a compassionate society would let boys
into the girls bathroom
and you know if like in loudoun county
some of these sexually confused boys
rape little girls that's you know that's
either we're going to cover it up like
loudoun county tried to do or finally
when when the secret comes out we're
just going to downplay it and it's not a
big deal and actually that's the cost of
progress sometimes little girls get
raped when men get to go into the girls
room but that's the cost of the
compassion of pretending that men are
women and indulging their delusions
right
that's the cost so people say jim banks
should not have the right to say that
it's mean it's hate speech it's wrong
and some conservatives
have have been so radicalized by this
they've gone completely in the opposite
direction and they i i think are also
making claims that are unfounded they're
saying you have the right to say
whatever you want this is the free
speech absolutist position that's kind
of the point i argue in my book
speechless
they say you have the right to say
whatever you want
with very very narrow exceptions you
should you have the god-given natural
right
to say whatever you want even if it's
totally nonsensical even if it's a lie
even if it's not true you have the right
to say it that isn't true either
you don't have the right to just say
whatever you want willy-nilly okay you
even from a first amendment perspective
there are plenty of
areas of speech that that are not
permitted
threats fighting words obscenity
the list goes on and on
you don't have the right to those things
and on a on a platform
the kind of libertarian-y types the the
squishes who defend big tech they have a
little bit of a point as well platforms
do have a right to enforce standards all
human societies have the right to
enforce standards
jim banks
all of us we do not have the right to
say whatever we want
we do however have the right to tell the
truth
we have the right to say true things
but in this society under this ruling
class increasingly we do not at all we
especially don't have the right to say
true things and we are obligated to say
false things that's the perversity here
okay it's not just that we don't have
free speech
absolutely and it's not just that there
is censorship all societies have
censorship
all societies have standards okay
the problem here is we're not allowed to
tell the truth and you actually do have
a right to tell the truth and you
actually have an obligation to tell the
truth
but according to our ruling class that
is cruel actually
on this specific issue of transgenderism
and what's going on in loudoun county
virginia
this virginia governor's race may hinge
on this question the biggest issue that
is afflicting the democrat candidate for
governor terry mcauliffe former governor
of virginia he wants to be governor
again is this issue of the schools and
specifically this issue in aladdin
county do parents have a right to
have a say in their kids education
do boys have a right to go into the
girls room even if it's going to lead in
some cases to violent rape do they have
a right because of these kooky
ideological ideas about gender and
progress
this debate which it seems like it's a
local debate in virginia is actually
bringing in the big guns barack obama
himself flew down to virginia to
campaign for terry mcauliffe to say that
all this stuff you're hearing
from the republicans all this stuff you
know this whole story about the girl
getting raped in a school bathroom in in
virginia
by a guy who wears a dress
that is just a culture war distraction
close your eyes close your ears and tune
it out
by the way speaking of the culture where
you may have heard last week the
entertainment goliath espn lost allison
williams who's a seasoned sports
reporter disney which is espn's parent
company is forcing its employees to
receive the fouchy algae or get fired
allison chose to wait until she tries to
have a child i think a very reasonable
prudent decision especially for a young
healthy woman to make
okay
but espn decided that they were going to
force americans to choose between their
livelihoods and their freedom to make
personal medical decisions so
we at the daily wire decided to uh
get into this fight i guess we've been
it for a long time we're very excited to
announce that we have signed allison
williams to lead a very special sports
series exclusively for our members more
details to come if you want premium
content if you want sports content
without the woke become a member
dailywire.com subscribe use code do not
comply at checkout for 25 off
dailywire.com subscribe use code do not
comply for 25 off and join the fight
also tune in to the morning wire
it's a great show great way to get your
news it's a great counter to some of
those lib programs like you know you
have the uh the new york times show they
have the new york times daily show and
they they come on with that really
smooth quiet way they say well welcome
welcome to the new york times morning
show my name is michael babababa and we
are and the republicans are really bad
and the democrats are really good and
fouchy is great and but they do it in
this way that's really kind of quiet and
subtle so you think you're getting the
news but you're not you're just getting
a bunch of left wing opinion well
we decided people deserve to get the
facts just the facts so we're giving it
to them tune in to the morning wire on
apple spotify wherever you listen to
podcasts leave a five star review if you
like what you hear we'll be right back
with a lot more
if you think that men are not actually
women and if you think that women have
the right to be women and you think that
men don't have the right to redefine
what it is to be a woman and you have
and you believe that young girls have
the right not to be threatened and
victimized by men in their own bathrooms
barack obama says you're just
you're just another cynical cultural
warrior distracting us
from the real issues
we don't have time
to be
wasting
on these phony trumped up culture wars
this fake outrage
that right-wing media pedals to juice
their ratings and the fact that he's
willing to go along with it instead of
talking about serious problems that
actually affect serious people
that's a shame
that's not what this election is about
that's not what you need virginia this
fake outrage that a ninth grade girl was
raped by a dude in a women's bathroom
this fake outrage no one's really
outraged by that right so obama i want
to be as charitable as i can to obama
he's saying one of two things here he's
either saying that the story is
completely fake
which it's not i mean at this point
daily wire broke the story so the
mainstream media the left-wing media
didn't want to cover it we broke the
story but now everyone is reporting on
it we forced the washington post to
report on this thing right this is
everywhere now so either obama is saying
implausibly that the story is false or
this is even more shocking
he's saying that you just shouldn't be
outraged about it look listen sometimes
little girls are going to get raped okay
that's progress that's the cost of
progress okay you didn't think that it's
like when barack obama was defending
obamacare after he had lied and lied and
lied about the cost of obamacare he said
you're not going to pay for it you're
not going to pay for it this is going to
be cheaper it's going to be better and
then what happened we found out
obamacare everyone's prices went up they
said well what you didn't think you were
going to get all that stuff for free did
you
you didn't
well he's saying the same thing here
he's saying the same thing here
what you didn't think you were going to
get all that social progress for free
did you
i don't know what's going on with my
impressions this week but my even my
obama's becoming a bill clinton
you didn't think that you were going to
get all i don't know i don't know i got
to go back my british accent's no good
anymore my obama's that's fine it's a
separate point that's what he's saying
how callous is that how crazy is that
there is an irony here because you'll
hear
dismissal
of the the culture wars from the left
but you'll hear it from some squishes on
the right as well and the irony here
is that the people who dismiss
the culture war
are always the most radical cultural
warriors
right because when we talk about the
culture war issues we're talking about
letting dudes into the girls room we're
talking about radically redefining
marriage we're talking about killing
babies to the tune of a million a year
we're talking about
all of these
very important issues
and obama's position on them is
yeah we should kill the babies and we
should be permitted to kill the babies
up until the point of birth yeah we
should radically redefine marriage away
from what it's been for all of human
history everywhere in the world and yeah
we should let boys go into the girls
room even if yeah unfortunately every so
often a girl is going to get raped
and even if just as a matter of
justice the men have no place in the
girls room
now come on stop focusing on that
culture war you're the culture warrior
barack obama
this is when the left says oh you
republicans you conservatives you're so
obsessed with sex
what are you talking about we didn't
start this we're not the ones who said
redefine marriage we're not the ones who
said push abortion everywhere we're not
the ones who
who said that you need to have thruffles
and quadruples and
redefine all sorts of
social and sexual relations you're the
ones doing that
and so
what we what we're being so gaslit here
because the left is the aggressor in all
of these cultural war battles and then
the minute that we object to their
insane harmful plans
they say that we're the ones who are
obsessed with the culture war no we're
not we're just saying no we're saying
hey actually maybe don't do that
actually maybe that's wrong maybe that's
going to have harmful effects come on
what's wrong with you guys we need to
get to the important issues like cutting
taxes a little and the squishes go along
with it the squishes on the conservative
side they say actually guys you know
look we
marriage it's over okay it's a
completely we we just totally
who cares
actually abortion who cares look we lost
abortion back in
in roe versus wade actually uh
pretending that men are women we lost
that it's over come on let the girls go
into the let the boys go into the girls
bathroom it's fine let's just focus on
taxes or whatever
let's just focus on occupational
licensing reform
this is what the squishes are saying
so yes you want to talk about the
culture war yes we here at the daily
wire in particular are leaning into the
cultural fight okay that was always the
point of this company and we're doing it
right now not just commenting on culture
but actually creating culture because
that's what matters
okay and nobody
freaking cares about some bean counting
technocratic work around the margins
reform of some
economic
aspect of this country
when you compare that to
killing a million babies a year upending
the bedrock social institution and
sending men into the girls room
you want to talk about a culture war
right now
in oakland
there is a a bust
a little you know
shoulder up statue of of a figure that
was just unveiled
the bust was of black panther party
co-founder huey p
newton
the black panther party was a violent
terrorist organization it's actually
been sort of refounded now to intimidate
voters who don't go along with them
but this guy alone just this guy huey p
newton
was infamous for regularly abusing women
in 1974 he was charged with murdering a
teenage prostitute because she had
disrespected him the black panther party
more broadly was known for kidnapping
people torturing people murdering people
including young helpless people there's
one incident in new haven the new haven
black panther party was particularly
notorious where they took an 18 year old
boy because they felt that he had
betrayed them and they beat him they
poured scalding water on him they
tortured him
the then they took him to a dock and
they they
lynched him with i think a
coat hanger
and then shot him in the head
and these people are being honored here
these people are getting statues put up
we're taking down statues of thomas
jefferson and george washington and we
are putting up statues of terrorists of
left-wing terrorists
these got the black panther party is as
bad as it gets okay
but because these are bad black guys
they are who who worked for left-wing
causes they are being
exalted as heroes
they are being whitewashed
to use a sort of ironic term that's
that's used a lot today we take down
christopher columbus we accuse columbus
of a bunch of things he didn't do
and then we tear down his statues even
though he founded this country none of
us would be here without him we tear
down washington statue we tear down
jefferson's and lincoln's the man who
freed the slaves to down his statue
and we put up statues of
psycho murderers
woman abusers
radicals because they serve the
political narrative do you get it yet do
you see it yet
i think there's a lot of waking up going
on right now
all right
this is in part why this word woke is so
popular on the left and why the term red
pill is so popular on the right they
both describe the same phenomenon which
is waking up from a dream
i think people are waking up from the
dream of 15 days to slow the spread that
was never about public health
it was always about a power grab tearing
down the statues it was never about the
alleged sins of christopher columbus or
thomas jefferson it was always about a
power grab a power grab by the left in
this country that hates
the way things were
it hates what the country was and maybe
to some degree still is and it wants to
radically change it
speaking of these bad guys
i think the tide is beginning to turn a
little bit i think people are getting a
little bit woke and they're getting a
little bit red pilled and they're
whatever term you want to use
specifically on fouchy
but what is turning the tide on fauci is
a little
unfortunate to me so you may have seen
this story over the weekend some some
documents were obtained
by the white coat waste project via a
freedom of information act request
that showed
that from october 2018 until february
2019
niaid that is the aspect of the national
institutes of health that dr fauci runs
and has run for decades spent 1.68
million dollars in taxpayer funds on
drug tests involving 44 beagle puppies
and the tests were pretty sick
a lot of them involved
well involved torturing the puppies i
guess that's that's how you'd put it you
know putting parts of the puppy's bodies
in little sealed containers with hungry
little flies that would eat the puppies
alive or you know poisoning the puppies
and then you know dissecting them and
looking at what the effect of that on
their organs or in one report said they
ripped out the vocal cords of puppies so
they wouldn't need to hear the puppies
scream while they were conducting these
these medical experiments on them and
and in effect torturing them
this is all very sad this has people
outraged bipartisan calls now for fauci
to resign or at least to be investigated
give an answer for this
i guess it's because i'm not a dog
person i don't know i'm not a dog person
i'm not a cat person i'm more a people
person
and i think it is an indictment of our
culture
that we are outraged
that dr fauci performed medical
experiments on beagles
but we don't care
that our government experiments on
babies on fetal stem cells
we create vaccines out of the cells of
killed babies
we kill almost a million babies a year
in this country through abortion that's
fine that's to be celebrated or to be
discussed in these very clinical terms
but if you conduct a medical experiment
on a puppy that's a bridge too far
because because according to these
people the beagles
are much more precious
than the babies
that's that's what they think
it's frustrating because i don't have
any problem with medical experimentation
on
animals i think it's actually a good
thing because you try out these
these
new treatments on animals and you see if
they work and if they don't work and
sometimes the treatments are going to
kill the animals and sometimes it's
going to improve the animals and then
this is a way of figuring out whether or
not it's going to work on people without
having to experiment on people whether
it's little babies or aborted fetal
cells or actual
adults you know fully grown adults in
the general population
right we don't
i would much rather experiment on a
beagle than on a human being at any
stage of development
whether we're talking about a little
baby
or a kid
or a teenager or an adult
i don't think animals have any rights i
don't think we should torture animals
but c.s lewis makes this point that the
problem with animal cruelty is not that
animals have some rights that we are
violating when we
torture them it's that
torturing animals will deaden our
humanity the problem is actually still
for us so we shouldn't do it we should
be good stewards of creation
but there's nothing wrong with medical
experiments on
animals there is something wrong with
medical experiments on little babies
okay and on
adult humans and everyone in between
speaking of life and death have to get
to this story it's part of the biggest
story of the weekend
alec baldwin killed a woman on the set
of his film rust so alec baldwin who's
a legendary actor and he's very
left-wing so a lot of conservatives hate
him but you got to give the guy credit
he's a very good actor and he's a good
dramatic actor and he's a very good
comedic actor and i i'm i mean whenever
the guy opens his mouth about politics i
want to pull my hair out but i've never
let that
completely turn me off the guy's
performances i think he's a good artist
so he was on set of this movie someone
handed him a prop gun
and he discharged the weapon
and the cinematographer ended up dead
and the director ended up injured
and that's pretty much all we know
so there's a lot of confusion here
we're being told that the weapons master
on the set
told baldwin that the gun was not loaded
it was a cold gun
and uh but but still it's up to the
actor not to point the gun at somebody
it's up to the actor not to be negligent
in his use of the gun
so a lot of conservatives
are really going after him
i've actually been on sets with guns in
my wayward youth when i was occasionally
in in a movie or two i've been on them
with guns and people tend to take this
very seriously even in really low budget
movies even in really
we're being told this movie rust was
relatively pretty low budget even though
it had a big star like baldwin in it but
i was once on a movie set and a weapon
was discharged and it wasn't like some
actor was just running willy-nilly
shooting in the air but you know there
were there were people around them and
they were kind of working through a
scene but because they had not totally
locked down the set and had everyone
there notified and ready for the gun to
go off when it went off this was a huge
deal they had to shut down the set i
mean it was a really big problem people
take this stuff seriously so there were
reports that that people had been
negligent on set that people said the
weapons were not safe obviously this
weapons master
if if the she told and reportedly was
very young like 24 year old weapons
master she was obviously wrong alec
baldwin very likely was negligent here
but my take on it is look there will be
some investigation if if alec baldwin
were criminally liable then obviously he
should be prosecuted for it but i think
conservatives are a little too quick
here to uh to just jump in and say
you know
lock him up and throw away the key
because we don't like his politics i do
think there is
something worth remembering here which
is that
sometimes bad things just happen
sometimes accidents just happen i'm not
saying maybe this was just absolute
criminal negligence but sometimes
accidents just happen too and it's a
very left-wing perspective to pretend
that if we only follow all the rules and
if we only you know get everything
perfectly
right in this rationalist scientific way
that nothing bad is ever going to happen
again and that's not true sometimes
there are just accidents okay and that's
that is a very conservative insight and
i think we need to recognize this
because that's that's true not just on
movie sets but that's true in our
politics it's true in all of our lives
so we might just want to
wait before we inadvertently
jump in and grant a lot of left-wing
premises about the way the world works
speaking of eternal things
joe biden
just came in this story didn't get a lot
of play but it really should because it
tells you a lot about
our ruling class
joe biden was just giving some speech
about politics and about how extremely
unpopular he is and how people still
kind of like trump and he was trying to
downplay this
and
joe biden
made a claim
that that related to his catholic
identity see if you can catch the
problem with this claim
something like 20 percent of the report
half the republicans the registered
republicans i am not your president
donald trump is still your president
as we catholics say oh my god
hahaha yakity yakyakyak as we catholics
say
do you notice
do you notice the problem here
he says as we catholics say
and then he immediately broke this the
second commandment not to take the
lord's name in vain
isn't that a little strange catholics
don't say this
catholics are obliged to avoid taking
the lord's name in vain
you might say oh michael what you've
never taken the lord's name in vain i
have i've i have sinned i've
committed all not every sin that there
is to commit i guess but a great deal of
sins and i am sorry for that but it's
not something that we should encourage
and as
is so often the case with joe biden
the problem here is not just that he is
committing these sins but he's also
committing the sin of scandal because he
is
presenting himself as a catholic
but he is violating so much of catholic
moral teaching
notably on abortion right he's saying
i'm a catholic but we should definitely
kill a million babies a year and that's
confusing that leads people astray and
that's a really big problem
and here you see the same thing for joe
biden
catholicism is a costume rather than a
faith
he does not
adhere to very important teachings of
the church he publicly flouts them with
the same contempt that you heard from
him at the very top of the show
when when joe biden said freedom come on
man freedom come on man he has the same
dismissal the same scorn for very
important aspects of his faith
he wears catholicism like a drag queen
wears a dress it's just
it's just for show haha he's making the
sign of the cross
very important symbol
as a kind of punch line as a joke
maybe other catholics have done we i
suspect many people have done this
before i have been guilty of this kind
of flippancy but you got to be sorry for
it you got to regret that you got to try
not to do it you certainly shouldn't
engage in the sin of scandal by publicly
flouting this sort of stuff but joe
biden's real faith
is liberalism
that's what it comes down to and nancy
pelosi's real faith her real religion is
liberalism and this is true for all of
these guys so they talk a good talk and
they think it's kind of folksy and cute
kind of like
an ethnicity almost
you know we catholics kind of like jude
you know judaism is an ethnicity and a
and a religion so they'll say we jews
you know even someone who hasn't
practiced the jewish faith in
decades they'll say we jews you know
it's a jewish thing it's just us because
there's a conflation here the same is
sometimes true for catholics because you
know especially irish catholics or
people who have a more ethnic connection
to it say oh we catholics we do but they
don't actually believe in these things
whenever there is a conflict between
catholicism and liberalism
joe biden nancy pelosi andrew cuomo
they will choose liberalism because
that's their true faith
speaking of religions
one of the
expressions of liberalism and
progressivism today and the religious
sphere is the religion of the sun
monster the religion of
the i guess you could call it the
religion of the unconquered sun that was
an old pagan religion in ancient rome
and i guess it's the same one today with
global warming so we've been told
by the scientists by the experts by the
geniuses for years
that
global warming is going to melt the
polar ice caps it's going to kill all
the polar bears and then one of the it's
going to melt the snows of kilimanjaro
and one of the big
signals of global warming according to
these experts is it's going to destroy
the great barrier reef the great barrier
reef in australia is being destroyed by
global warming
al gore and all the rest of them have
talked about this for years this is a
big marker of of the real threat of
global warming
well the australian government just
released an official report on reef
recovery showing that the northern great
barrier reef has continued to increase
27
from the most recent low point in 2016.
the central barrier reef saw a 26
increase in hard coral cover the study
states that over 35 years of monitoring
the great barrier reef has consistently
quote shown an ability to recover after
disturbances
you're not hearing any of this
just like al gore told us the snows of
kilimanjaro would be gone by oh by now
actually by years ago and it wasn't true
just like we were told all the polar
bears are going to drown and the the
snow was going to go away on the caps
that didn't happen well the same thing
we were told here and it just isn't true
and it just reminds me
of everything we've been talking about
today dr fauci we were told emphatically
no gain of function research none of it
in wuhan turns out that wasn't true at
all janet yellen tells us we will
recover we're going to recover
within a few months oh no actually the
prices are going to keep increasing
until the end of next year we're going
to this for 15 days to slow the spread
the polarized caps are melting the great
barrier reef and it's all just bunk it's
just not true
okay
how many more
major claims
do the ruling class need to be proven
wrong on
before
we recognize they have
no
credibility
you know
the the scientists the scientistic
people
are so often wrong
right this is the one thing we know
about science is science is always
wrong statistic because the there's some
prevailing scientific consensus and then
it gets completely blown up by the next
generation and you wonder how is this
possible how is it that the smartest
people
who have the best degrees and they know
all the details about something they can
be so much dumber
than
your average joe schmoe on the street
who knows that the sun monster isn't
going to destroy the world in five
minutes
it reminds me of a saying i forget
exactly who pointed it out it's the
difference between knowledge and wisdom
knowledge is knowing that a tomato is a
fruit
and wisdom is not putting it in a fruit
salad and i think that's what you're
seeing here the
ronald reagan made a similar point he
said the problem with our
with the democrats now we might say the
problem with our ruling class is not
that they're ignorant it's that they
know so many things that aren't so
and i think it's time that we just
ignore them that when the fouchies of
the world or the bidens or the yellens
or somebody say something we can almost
be confident that the opposite is going
to be true and we do still have
political power to push back against
them and they're seeing that now and
they're feeling that pressure have that
confidence we're right they're wrong
stick by it and push ahead i'm michael
knowles it's the michael noel show see
you tomorrow
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring our technical director is austin
stevens supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2021. on
the matt wall show we talk about the
things that matter real issues that
affect you your family our country not
just politics but culture faith current
events all the fundamentals if they
matter to you come check out the show